c'est un actif extraordinaire puis je
peux vous dire que notre notre
initiative fait l'envie de gens
Hydro-Québec à payer le double du
montant qui avait déboursé en 2017 la
compagnie outlet Capital Partner pour
l'achat de 13 central hydroélectrique la
PDG d'Hydro-Québec se fibrochu assure
que l'investissement est rentable c'est
un prix tout à fait correct pour nous et
il va être porteur à travers les
décennies
c'est très central elles sont situées
sur deux rivières qui traversent le
Vermont le New Hampshire et le
Massachusetts les rivières d'un field et
connecticute ensemble leur puissance
s'élève à 589 mégawatts ces trois font
moins que le barrage de Manix 5 mais
assez pour fournir un électricité 213000
foyers en Nouvelle Angleterre c'est très
bien exporté mais un moment donné quand
c'est un marché qui est très stratégique
il faut être capable d'être un citoyen
d'avoir des activités sur sur place
Hydro-Québec soutient avoir une
stratégie commerciale de partenariat
avec les Américains plutôt que d'avoir
une même mise sur leurs installations
hydroélectriques une initiative qui
pourrait être bénéfique à long terme
pour les Québécois même si l'énergie
produite demeurera aux États-Unis ce
n'est pas à travers la production de
énergétique de ces barrages que l'équipe
quoi vont en tirer profit mais c'est à
travers la profitabilité a été
financière que Hydro-Québec va obtenir
pendant qu'il est au Québec investit à
l'étranger d'autres projets comme la
construction de barrages tel que
souhaitée par le Premier ministre
François Legault pourrait prendre forme
la question est de savoir si la société
d'État aura la capacité de mener tous
ses projets de front ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal